When learning a language on your own for the
first time, it’s hard to know what path
to follow.
There are so many popular methods, strategies,
and learning pathways out there that most
people just pick the first method they find
and start learning.
This works well for a while, but most people
soon find that the method they’re using
is too boring, too stressful, or simply too
abstract, and unable to help them use their
target language productively.
What if there were a better way?
What if you could find a tried-and-tested
method that is:
Well-organized, and structured according to
the major language skills?
Capable of helping you memorize words and
sentences easily and naturally?
Able to develop your ability to think directly
in your target language?
Built upon a foundation of stress-free feedback?
Both fun and rewarding?
Fortunately, there’s no need to wonder.
In this video, I’ll be sharing with you
some of the foundational concepts of that
method.
And don’t forget to stay tuned till the
very end, because I’ve got a surprise for
you that you won’t want to miss!
Hello, I am Luca Lampariello, I am a language
coach who speaks 14 languages.
On this channel, I help people learn foreign
languages more efficiently, faster, and in
a fun way.
This video is part two in a series on how
to start learning a new language.
By now, I’ll assume you have seen the first
video of the series and picked up a high-quality
beginner resource based on the recommendations
I made there.
But if you haven’t seen that video yet,
go check it out now—I’ve included a link
in the description box.
Once you have your beginner resource in hand,
you can start working on the one activity
that will be the backbone of all of your future
language learning success—building skills!
This is an important detail that often gets
overlooked, because language learning is,
first and foremost, about acquiring skills.
About learning how to read, write, speak,
and listen, along with all of the countless
subskills that any competent language speaker
has in his or her toolbox.
In traditional classroom settings, the development
of skills often gets overlooked in favor of
facts.
Facts in the form of conjugation tables, word
lists, grammar explanations, the names of
verb tenses, and so on.
All of these things are related to language,
but it’s important to realize that knowing
these things has nothing to do with speaking
and using a language productively.
For example, did you ever consult a verb table
when learning your native language?
I don’t think so!
So my method, the method I’m going to be
talking to you about today, doesn’t waste
your time with such things.
Instead, I’ll be teaching you how to use
translation to develop a core of authentic
language skills—the very skills that native
speakers of your target language use each
and every day!
Let’s dive in:
Step 1: Gain a Deep Understanding of the Content
In Part 1 of this series, I spoke at length
about the importance of bilingual texts, and
in particular, bilingual dialogues with accompanying
audio files.
Now, if you’ve followed my advice, the resource
you’ve chosen contains many of these dialogues,
which you’ll now be using to begin learning
your target language.
In this first step, the goal is to learn how
to take these beginner dialogues—which should
come in both your native and target languages—and
use them to develop a deep understanding of
what the target language version of the dialogue
actually means.
As an absolute beginner, the first skills
you’ll need to develop are listening and
reading.
That way, you’ll be able to interpret the
sounds of your target language, and decipher
the written language used to represent those
sounds.
Luckily, your bilingual dialogues should have
everything you need to start listening and
reading quickly.
Once you get comfortable with following along
with the text and audio, you can develop a
deeper understanding of the content of the
dialogue in a number of ways.
For example:
Read the target language text and listen to
the audio at the same time
Read the text in your target language only,
without audio
Read the text in your native language only
Read the text out loud in your target language
Compare both the target language and native
language versions of the dialogue, and use
the accompanying grammar notes to clarify
any details you did not originally understand.
Completing these activities will help you
progressively gain a deeper and deeper understanding
of what any given dialogue in your coursebook
actually means.
At this stage, focus solely on grasping what
the dialogue means—don’t worry about translation
or memorization yet.
Those will come later.
Step 2: Translate the Text into Your Native
Language
Now that you understand what the target language
version of your dialogue is supposed to mean,
we’re going to complete our first translation
step—taking the target language text and
translating it into your native language.
Since your chosen beginner resource likely
comes with a native-language translation of
the dialogue already, you might be curious
why this is necessary.
The answer is personalization.
Your brain is more likely to memorize information
that it deems important or personally meaningful
to you.
Straight out of your textbook, the dialogue
you’ve been working on probably doesn’t
have much personal relevance.
Someone else wrote the dialogue, so it’s
not something that’s unique to you or your
circumstances.
By taking the target language dialogue, and
using what you’ve learned so far to translate
that dialogue into your own words, you’re
doing two things:
Creating a unique, more personal, and more
memorable version of the dialogue
Paying deeper attention to the content and
structure of the original dialogue, so you
can translate it faithfully into your own
language.
Together, these 2 steps will help further
solidify your knowledge of the dialogue, and
make it much easier to memorize the words
and phrases it contains.
At this point, it’s important to consider
how you’ll perform this translation, and
where you’ll keep it.
For most people, I recommend either:
Writing the translation by hand into a dedicated
language notebook
Typing the translation and saving it using
software like Google Docs, or Evernote.
Personally, I enjoy typing my translations
into a Google Doc.
Typing allows me to complete the process quite
quickly, and doing so in word-processing software
allows me to move and reformat things easily.
Step 3: Translate the Text Back into Your
Target Language
Now for the final step.
You’re going to take your personalized,
native language version of the original dialogue,
and translate it back into your target language.
This is the most powerful step of this entire
process, since it provides a number of key
benefits:
It tests your brain’s ability to recall
what it learned in the earlier two steps
It tests your ability to form phrases and
sentences in your target language
It compels you to think directly in your target
language, so that your final sentences convey
the correct meaning
So, where do we start, how do we actually
do this?
First we actually start by waiting.
Once you’ve completed the native language
translation in the last step, it’s best
to wait anywhere from 24 to 48 hours before
translating your dialogue back into your target
language.
Why should you wait?
Because waiting helps you forget!
And why should you forget?
Because information that is forgotten and
then later recalled will actually create stronger
memories than information that was never forgotten
at all in the first place.
Traditional schooling teaches us that forgetting
is a bad thing, but neuroscience research
has shown that forgetting plays this fundamental
part in memorization.
To repeat, if we forget something and then
are reminded of what we’ve forgotten, we
will remember it better in the future.
By waiting a day or two to complete your second
translation step, you’ll be taking advantage
of this important neural mechanism.
Once you’re ready to translate back, here’s
what you should keep in mind:
Translate sentence by sentence
Read your entire native language version of
each sentence first, and then attempt to convey
the meaning of that sentence into your target
language.
Avoid translating word-by-word, if possible.
If you find that you’ve forgotten a word
or phrase, try to wrack your brain for three
to ten seconds, and try hard to remember it.
If you still can’t remember after that time,
leave a blank space in your translation, and
look it up later.
Once you look them up, those forgotten words
and phrases will be more strongly remembered
going forward.
When you’ve finished this “reverse translation”
step to the best of your ability, you can
compare your new target language version with
the original version in your coursebook.
This step provides the “stress-free” feedback
I hinted at earlier, as it helps you observe
the kinds of mistakes you make in the language,
as well as the kinds of things you’re more
likely to both forget and remember.
So there you have it!
These are the three key steps that will help
you start learning any language through translation.
To recap, those steps are:
Gain a deep understanding of the content
Translate the text into your native language
Translate the text back into your target language
These steps are a distillation of the method
I’ve used to learn ten of the fourteen languages
I speak today.
If you put them to use, and do so often, you’ll
quickly begin to read, understand, and think
in your target language—even as a beginner!
If you’d like to learn more about this method—including,
among other things, the powerful learning
plan that will help you rotate through these
activities consistently and efficiently—take
a look in the description box below.
I’ve left a link to my brand-new online
course, which will teach you everything you
need to know about putting my Bidirectional
Translation to work for you, so you, too,
can learn any language!
As always, thanks for watching, and happy
language learning!